- What can you do to eliminate your
double chin besides surgery?
Would eating carrots do
anything to my jawline?
What are you, Bugs Bunny bro?
(upbeat music)
Like, you mean like to make your
muscles stronger in your neck?
(laughs)
There was a funny commercial
Christiano Ronaldo
if I'm not mistaken did where,
please don't buy the chin exercise
or whatever it's called.
You can't spot reduce where
you have a problem area.
You can lose overall body fat which can
help possibly your double chin.
Surgery is an option.
Fillers are an option.
Soo Great 123, why does your heart race
and your hands get clammy when you
see someone you have a crush on?
This happens to me a lot.
That's called arousal.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- That's a normal, sympathetic
nervous system in action.
Your body's getting you prepared.
It's getting excited.
It's being turned on.
Those are good things, it means you're
feeling some kind of
passion for that person.
You should enjoy that feeling
and really live in the moment.
What is your opinion on birth control
making women gain weight?
I've never had this problem, but I hear
so many complaints about it.
Maddie, it does happen occasionally.
What happens the majority of the time
actually is women initially put on weight
from starting birth control,
but it's usually water weight that if you
stay on the birth control long enough
it equalizes and you actually end up
losing the water weight
that you initially gained.
My recommendation to my patients is
to stay with it, to try it, if it doesn't
work the way that they
want we could always
switch medications or try
another form of birth control.
Imhs 37, hi Dr. Mike, just want to know
is it bad to cross your legs often?
Been trying to find this
out but to no avail.
Thank you.
I see what you're saying
because you're compressing
your blood vessels, your veins,
and your arteries when
you cross your legs.
Sometimes your legs get pins and needles,
they go numb as a result.
So yeah, I generally would
say don't cross your legs.
But, at the same time it's
not that big of a deal.
If you listen to your
body and you start feeling
any kind of discomfort,
change your position.
It's really that simple.
Katia Bufanda, hey Dr. Mike I have been a
licensed massage therapist for going on
five years now and I
find that some doctors
can still be hesitant to recommend massage
or believe the benefits
of massage therapy.
What are your thoughts on massage?
Actually, true story
me and my man Dan Owens
here who is sitting behind the camera
are going to get a massage after this,
specifically a Thai massage.
I personally believe in
the benefits of massage.
I also see the scientific
benefits of massage.
What feels good to your muscles?
Blood flow.
How can you stimulate
blood flow naturally?
Well, you can break up restrictions.
You can rub the muscle which will
bring more blood flow to that area,
some warmth, some healing factors.
Dynamic Butter, dear Dr.
Mike, I think my crush
has crush on you.
What should I do?
You should become a poet because that was
a really good line right there.
Actually, Dynamic Butter,
what you should do
is you should tell your crush that
I'm answering your question right now
and maybe that'll give
you some kind of cred
and you can then like, vibe.
I don't know what you
kids call it these days.
Biggest question, how to
stop being a lazy ass.
My answer here is going to surprise you.
Most people think will
power comes prior to action.
They think that they're just going to
wake up motivated one day and then they're
going to take action.
No.
It happens the other way and it's
a little bit surprising.
You have to perform some sort of action
and as a result of whatever action
you perform, you're going
to get some benefit.
Feel good chemicals, mastery of a subject,
improvement, admiration of others, fun.
As a result of that, you're going
to get motivation and will power
which then you could
use to do other tasks.
Kargace 100, why are
almost all medical terms
so long and hard to pronounce?
Like deoxyribonucleic acid?
That's just DNA.
I think it's because
a lot of medical terms
are derived from Latin.
Latin is a complicated language
and you can combine terms by putting
just a simple O in between them.
I also think, and this is
my conspiracy theory here,
all right turn on the Shane Dawson music.
Do do do do do.
It's because doctors don't want you
to understand what they're saying
because then they're not as special
and I think lawyers do this.
I think all specialties do this.
Just use the regular terms.
If it's front, say front.
If it's back, say back.
Doctors, what are you doing?
Cody Mehmet Catal, I
hope I said that right.
The real question, how
much Dr. Mike is too much?
Only after you've watched
all of my hundred plus
videos three times over and then
watch them one more time for good luck,
that might be too much.
Rebecca V, question, why is it that
some people sneeze louder than others?
Is it dangerous to sneeze quietly?
I would not curtail your sneezes
because when your curtail your sneezes
you're raising the
pressure inside your head,
the intracranial pressure, unnecessarily.
Just enjoy the feeling of a sneeze,
but sneeze correctly.
Don't sneeze into your hand.
Don't just sneeze into the world.
Sneeze into your elbow
so that the bacteria
can stay in your elbow and you won't
spread it to the rest of the
world by touching things.
What's the deal with stage fright because
I go on stages very
often these days and it
really bugs me before
and while being on stage?
Angelina, you're not alone.
The biggest fear in the
world is not heights.
It's not spiders.
It's the fear of public speaking or some
other form of social anxiety.
I've suffered from this.
My friends have suffered from this.
The more times you're
able to expose yourself
to that kind of situation,
the better you're
going to perform and the
better your going to do.
The second thing about
that is if you're able
to look inside yourself
and wonder why is it
that I'm so nervous about going on stage
and you can confront those fears,
for example if you say to yourself,
well if I stutter people are
going to think I'm stupid.
Pause right there.
Is that thought rational?
That if you stutter once, someone's going
to think you're totally stupid?
Possible, not likely and
if they do they're the ones
that are making the incorrect conclusion.
Think about what's making you nervous
to go on stage, attack those thoughts,
write them down if it will help you,
put the more rational
thought in it's place
and then go out and keep doing it.
It's never going to totally go away,
but that's a good thing.
That's you're mind getting you ready
to go on stage and think quickly
to answer people's questions
and perform your very best.
Vikkie Piercy, P.S. does anyone else
think Dr. Mike seriously looks like
Manny the makeup artists
sexy straight brother?
Well, thank you for the sexy compliment.
Yeah, we've been told this before.
In fact, that's how Manny
and I started talking
on Twitter because someone tagged us
and said that we look really similar.
We actually get along well and we chat
via Twitter all the time.
We're supposed to get a collab going
sometime soon, but
because we're on opposite
coasts of the United
States it's not that easy
but I think it may be in the works.
Kortizi00, what is a book you read
recently that you enjoyed?
I really enjoyed Jonathan Haidt's
"The Coddling of the American Mind".
Actually, I enjoyed it
so much that I'm going
to be reading one of his other books
"The Righteous Mind" I think it's called.
A lot of his thoughts that he put
very eloquently in his book I've thought
for a long time in my
practice with my patients,
the things that I've observed in college
when I was there, and the things that are
happening on social media.
So, I think that if you're interested
in that kind of reading material,
definitely worth checking it out.
(upbeat lo-fi music)